[Music]
in got milk news
that's a Teddy's old oh yeah submitted
by JK forever that's right
bull ever is it about dough kiddies a
woman describes drinking her friend's
breast milk for a week oh she's sucking
on her friend's titties exactly direct
oder eglee know what i would want with
me what's newsworthy is if she was
sucking on her her guy friends dick
titty for milk for a week but guys don't
lactate we lacked a down there condensed
milk identify as a girl and this is my
one boob yeah this is what I want you to
experiment but girls don't even suck on
titties identified as a girl no but they
experiment oh [ __ ] you're right that's a
big flaw that's a big flaw in the plan
identify as straight so I wouldn't suck
your one boobie but she might be
straight but she just wants to
experiment with titty milk will work
shopping actually sucking it from the
breasts every day we trying to think of
a new scheme to get you guys to suck our
dick how about I have a dick oh my god
does not work you've never said it I
know right now I'm dumb watch it when I
do
to pull down your pants right now this
moment a time in a place let's go ahead
go ahead what's locking her no no put
your head around here well you I mean if
you want the real size then here not
this way this way is that a privacy
curtain yes it's like you're picking
your teeth this article it's one of
those vice articles really try to do
something for a week and then see how
they feel oh yeah worth like by speed
try to Vice tries to be like a edgy
BuzzFeed when they try that yeah it's
like one of those so this woman who
works for Vice she got some milk from
her co-worker because she's saying that
her co-workers two-year-olds is there
any weaning away from wean loss a long
time I heard that it's very good for the
child to be drinking as much titty milk
as possible it's like mainly the first
three months I get the most like that
one is important but after three months
it's like we don't matter if you want
but some people are like free of food
yeah it's free but like for tyka most
babies - once he hits one she wants to
transition transition him over to calm
my chicken and then more solids than
milk but what if they're allergic to
milk like cow milk yeah would it can
they do like like Leia's allergic to a
bunch of [ __ ] she was allergic to the
formula there's just different things so
wait so this chick is just like I Drive
my friend's titty milk yeah for a week
did it taste good every day for a week
so she said that it tastes really good
really sweet yeah I heard it's really
sweet I always wanted I was craving
titty milk in elementary I was like mom
how come on I have to milk do you
remember I removed your call doing it
though you were like I want the how I
want the hand
yeah like that booby milk you know my
mom made me so dis they're not distance
that my mom made me hate it because
anytime I would whine about some
t-shirts like here do you want to suck
on my tit then but it's mannish and it
just sounds any more vulgar so I can't
put it pretty about that putting about
how you say it
um I forgot now cuz I'm thinking of the
story and then I'm like oh that's so
nice I wanna suck yeah my mom can't cash
it on these I would've sucked down like
a smartass yep like if mom you want me
to do it I'll look I'll suck on it take
a picture you show you two co-workers Oh
claims that by drinking breast milk and
it can improve your skin a work wonders
for your immune system help build muscle
it was revealed with calories with as
contact solution what a body suit found
that out her babies though I don't know
told exactly so she talked to she talked
to me that some professionals and she
found out that be like breast milk it's
just for babies like that's meant it's
meant to help babies as grown-ups
there's not really a lot of nutritional
value yeah you have to get different
breast milk in Tigers Eye one time yeah
cuz it was like one of his tear ducts
was clogged and then I called the
pediatrician she's I just put some of
your like a couple drops of breast milk
in there Mike what the [ __ ] and then I
did it and then how did they ever find
that out that's probably what this thing
smell just antibodies and then they're
like oh I probably hear what everybody
one more time Bart
you sound so scientific antibodies whoa
well they're saying that the IgG know
you they're at a scientist you are you
jealous
yeah is that the same Sheila's
antibiotics you married the right one
no they did say that ancient Egyptians
would use this to treat wounds to breast
milk oh yeah well they're [ __ ] bad
that's why Egyptians worship you
beware what the [ __ ] did they know right
yeah they died so it didn't work they
made a pyramid could they try to make
extra breast milk through that
[ __ ] physical titty yeah they
found that's cuz the aliens interjected
that's right some ancient aliens I know
and in the pyramid was supposed to be a
generator for electricity yep yeah and
they built the airport to run first
spacecraft and then they hung out with
their friends in South America and also
you could never have gotten a rock that
straight with any old ancient tools you
had to use modern equipment yeah you're
married a very smart guy too
she married an ancient alien theorists
thank you historian historian it's a
ancient astronaut historian right
astronaut yeah that's what they call
really yeah they call him an imaginary
ins it's called ancient astronaut theory
what the difference between them and a
sci-fi novelist that they're on the
History Channel
yeah they gave a personality to the
aliens I like it I really like it I like
I saw a video of a guy crying while he
talked about how aliens made him jerk
off into a metal jar he was so emotional
people of Earth I think it's called TV
show it's really funny it reminds me of
that cuz it's a whole bunch it's a group
of people that they've all had alien
encounters it's a fiction or it's real
like people the people are real I like
to write like the real ship where it's
like I
I was taken when I was 13 years old I
was taken up into a craft I'm at that
time the leader spoke to me and said I
was gonna be okay then they put this
silver tube up my ass and made me jerk
off into a cup like those are the
characters that shows based off of it
yeah I don't care for alien does that I
just hope I come back better than before
so I don't have to go to the doctor like
I hope they go out I'm just you know I
got a test them but then you know like
when when we tag our animals like in the
wild yeah and then they kind of like
put like a GPS on the [ __ ] whale or
whatever but sometimes they call the
[ __ ] legs broken or whatever there's
no way no III switch the animals I knew
Wells have legs yeah look it up sometime
I believe anyway back to the breast milk
yeah they're also saying that a lot of
people who go through chemotherapy they
they drink breast milk because it helps
them with the side effects like nausea
upset stomach loss of appetite and so
like she interviewed this one person who
started taking drinking it that's pretty
cool and it really helped her thank you
yeah that whole food is probably you are
probably not routes yeah yeah this
doesn't make me want to suck on a titty
like for milk there are a lot of apps or
websites that have apps that women who
just produce a lot of milk where they
don't need their breast milk anymore but
they want to make extra money they sell
their I would need to know what they eat
me too I want someone eating KFC all day
giving me their breast milk yeah we good
yeah it doesn't taste like right Jane
mg says that it tastes like really very
important my body order really see the
man she said it was like she said it
reminds her a very watery or Chuck I
wonder if it's like comer if they taste
really sweet
are you how Mike okay
I love both Ellie yeah how my cos
hibiscus flower oh I was thinking jicama
oh no I don't like eat them up she
doesn't like it it's like anything he
says he's like wood yeah that's what I
like about coconut okay Casey doesn't
like haters like Ruth no it's [ __ ]
it's like a it's like a tasteless pear
yeah I think what's the point
like don't waste no bomb yeah Lyman
Sahin and all that [ __ ] no it just
tastes like Lyman thought he would
yeah I know that Asian pear yeah it's
like that but with not without the sweet
it's really hard this it's second right
I don't even know if I rate that we all
the time yeah yeah why would you how
about at the cafeteria yeah that's what
they gave us do you like an apple no
it's like cutting two sticks
oh oh look at that lime Oh French fries
yeah I'll throw that in but in the fruit
mix yeah on the side of the street right
that's pretty good but it's because I'm
eating the lime and then yeah yeah it's
all about the TV no we're never eaten by
this often is like
[Music]